[Musique]
bonjour n'ya pas le patrick araste donc
mêlés aux cours au département au
service 10 récent des transports
routiers au moins passer surveillant de
travaux donc non mais mon métier
consiste à surveiller la mise en oeuvre
de toutes les travaux que le département
fait sur les routes de secteur ouest
[Musique]
donc là ne l'est sur la route
départementale numéro un donc la rd1 qui
part de la ville de la possession sur et
orale et qui sauva via le villa du dos
d'âne
ce littoral c'est qu'on s'aime beaucoup
plus le bas de la ville de la possession
où la démographie urbaine est quand même
assez important et nous on devait relevé
le vilarino dame que de plus en plus qu
il fréquente un tourisme vert
tout ce qui dit randonnée tous qui dit
villages nature
[Musique]
e
et après un week-end noir quand même une
augmentation de gens qui sortent de
littoral qui vient chercher l'air frais
dans les eaux est d'autant plus que le
département a une politique aussi de
développement des os
c'est ça qui fait que l'augmentation de
la circulation que ce soit piétonne ou
véhicule est devenue très importante
[Musique]
on
nous on est là sur cette route en
particulier c'est que permettent l'accès
de son intention au départ mentale vers
ses grands axes de circulation que tout
le monde connaît le dessus au littoral
il faut que je donne sept à dix ans deux
de conduite et de circulation
[Musique]
oh